já é hora já é hora de nós falarmos com
mais força e com mais poder
já é hora de nós usarmos a nossa voz
tudo potencial expressivo que ela tem a
voz feminina ela tem o poder de praga se
a mulher como ser a mulher que trabalha
a mulher que realiza como acabou de
dizer senhor
a mulher que a mãe nós temos próximo por
favor nós temos uma identidade local
assim como nós temos uma impressão
digital que nos marca
nós também temos uma impressão local
cada um de nós tem uma voz é única que
não existe nenhuma mais igual no mundo
brasil como nós podemos detectar uma
pessoa por sua impressão digital
nós também podemos enfrentar tenha uma
pessoa pela sua impressão vocal a voz
quando é produzida
ela é produzida pelo ar que sai dos
mas passa longe nem aqui na alerj a onde
o homem é uma saliência que forma o povo
de adam se for eu chamo de culto ela as
mulheres estão as pregas vocais
quando é falar são empregados quanto o
ar passa as regras locais é fino e esse
som é amplificado nos nossos relacionado
à dores
os restauradores superiores que é mais a
nossa caixa italiana e os nossos
questionadores inferiores que é parte da
nossa caixa torácica
esse som é reverberado ele se expande no
espaço e as pessoas podem desenvolver
eles têm harmônicos que dão a nossa
identidade e as palavras elas são
formadas com os movimentos dos lábios
língua estrutura interna que nós temos
que vão nos dar uma palavra que pode ser
a palavra amor
aonde eu falo a palavra amor com a minha
voz e outra pessoa pode falar a palavra
[Música]
o início da nossa parte nós tivemos duas
restantes
que apareceram e foi bem interessante
mulher que tendo que já tem quatro pela
vontade de pegar e exemplificar com elas
era uma negra quem estava aqui viu com
uma voz mais grave uma pessoa que tinha
um pescoço mais custo e depois se uma
pessoa branca toda mais alongada com uma
voz mais aguda e em trouxe o exemplo
dessas duas mulheres para a gente
perceber a uma estrutura física é essa
estrutura ela interfere na produção do
som então nós temos aqui uma brasileira
e uma estrangeira
temos uma grande lago diack certo um
rosto mais fino uma estrutura leal mais
estreita
por outro lado temos o pescoço mais
custo com o rosto mais cheio lácteos com
mais massa e tudo isso ajuda a
determinar
após essa pessoa então agora vocês podem
quando conversava com alguém começar a
olhar no pescoço bom eu acho que esse
vai falar um pouco mais agudo
ele vai falar um pouco mais grave e no
novo universo começa a se abrir para que
a gente perceba o outro e também possa
ficar tv
só que essa estrutura é apenas um mau
martin da nossa voz
ela não representa o todo
existe uma outra parte que é a parte
emocional que é a marte como nós vemos o
mundo que é para ver como nosso curso
vimos a nossa auto estima é parte e que
não somos tratadas dentro da nossa
família
então se nós temos uma família
se essa criança tenha uma família que a
trata como princesa e uma princesa não
pode sujar e não pode gritar e não pode
discordar dela é nós estamos tratando
essa criança quando fazemos isso de uma
forma muito utilizada
e quando essa menina crescer ela vai
trazer em sua voz
traços de infantilidade
existem muitas mulheres que são adultas
e ao mesmo tempo tem uma voz infantil
às vezes a criança é tratada com
violência
o ego do nada ou vive um ambiente
familiar de muito conflito
ela pode se retrair se entristecer e tem
uma voz bem pequena e ela cresce se
expressando frente ao mundo com essa voz
uma voz abafada uma voz que fica presa
na garganta e mesmo quando adulta em
situações em que se exige que ela fab
ela terá dificuldade
o melhor é podemos crescer em família se
gration sermos quem somos
quando uma criança
estado uma menina como um ser que gosta
de brincar que gosta de subir em árvore
que gosta de se sujar o que pode evitar
que brinca que ela quer
há chances que ela tem de ter uma voz
natural de ter brilho de sua voz é muito
grande e aí a gente pode perguntar o
seguinte isso acontece com todas as
crianças ou seja todas as crianças que
passaram por essa situação
vão ter uma voz infantil ou todas as
mulheres que têm traços infantis na voz
é pitbull ex essa infância
não necessariamente claro que cada caso
é um caso
nós podemos perceber que na história das
mulheres
isso acontece com bastante freqüência e
nos homens os homens a trazem também
inscrito na sua voz à sua história
emocional além da estrutura física
aquilo que eles passaram também pode
acontecer e só que o que nós vimos com
mais freqüência é que as mulheres têm
mais de cinco mil
os locais e não é a gente porque a
mulher fala mais do que o homem isso não
é verdade
os homens são muito mais que as mulheres
se nós observarmos em um grupo de
pessoas é digamos uma reunião social
um grupo de homens e um grupo de
mulheres as mulheres estarão conversando
e os jovens estavam dando risada
falando alto porque eles marcam o seu
território com a sua voz também então a
entrada dessa voz mais externa mas
marcante para mostrar e eu estou aqui
enquanto que a mulher ela conversa mas
conversa com uma outra é intensidade com
uma outra intenção também é o que nós
vemos muito é que as mulheres as
mulheres têm mais dificuldade em dizer
não às mulheres atendem mais são
treinadas para é estar à disposição e
muitas vezes dentro dessa desse
comportamento
fica aquele nome é coogan aquele sapo
que não desce aquele incômodo que está
presa dia não consegue soltar
isso acontece falando fisiologicamente
porque é uma pressão 111 fechamento
laranja e uma elevação da laringe que
ela percebe que de sob alguma forma a
uma ameaça
então para proteger as vias aéreas a
lente se feche e aí fica uma rosa
fica uma voz em que as mulheres quando
vamos falar de sair uma fase dentro
estava ou sem projeção se nós pensarmos
em uma briga de um homem e uma mulher
normalmente o que acontece
a mulher começa falando com o aluno
normal você fez o que nós combinamos que
o homem pode responder à não deu tempo
deixei pra fazer amanhã
a mulher fala começa a estruturar o
acordo é que o cultivo de algumas coisas
pra fazer não te preocupa nem eu faço eu
ia falar
a voz em mulher se casa nesta segunda é
mais comum do que tenho a gente imagina
o quanto nós estamos emocionados e
encontramos uma amiga
é uma emoção que faz a voz
subir é um já é tempo de nós escutavam
os pais a nossa voz
já é tempo de nós nos inteirarmos a
nossa voz
e foi dessa forma que essa pessoa chegou
até mim é uma mulher de 43 anos muito
poderosa
com uma formação da inglaterra na
espanha nos estados unidos
uau uau chegou com a queixa de que com
duas horas de palestra a voz ela ficava
amarrada e ela não conseguirá atende o
meio
nós trabalhamos durante o levantamento
do histórico dessa pessoa
nós vemos que ela se relacionava com a
mãe é sempre aos gritos e com paz
silenciando porque o pai tinha uma força
tão potente que fazia com que ela ter
mesmo vai além disso ela sempre ouvia do
pai que não estava bom o suficiente
aquilo que ela fazia então a priminha
muito com a gente pode ver com esse
currículo ela não ficou no espaço da
menina que se retrai não pode fazer nada
ela saiu do mundo
só que agora
voz havia uma tensão na voz dela que o
excesso do aumento de uso da voz fez com
que ela precisa se trabalhar durante o
trabalho que apareceu mostrava uma foto
num registo mais agudo do que é o
registro natural e por que ela fazer
isso para não se identificar com o pai
que tinha uma voz muito forte e é uma
baixa popularidade negativa para ela e
na base da nossa menina
a voz dela era no espectro mais grave
que é a voz que eu sugiro agora e é uma
voz que tem veludo e o que essa pessoa
fala que as pessoas estão ouvindo mais
quando ela fala que quando ela pede
alguma coisa ela é atendida mais
rapidamente e que ela está mais centrada
nos ouvem dilemas que ela faz
queria trazer pra vocês
a história de época é um mito é é a da
grécia
ela era uma imensa muito alegres e larry
que fala da ilha ea esposa de zeus hera
se cansou do barulho na época de um
castigo pra ela que ela não poderia mais
falar por conta própria ela só poderia
reproduzir os sons a fala que ela
ouvisse
são se retrai viu esse assunto das
outras em face e ficou mais isolado não
possa um dia ela tiver sisu tomando efe
o papa ela filmar sisu e ficou
completamente apaixonada e tentou chamar
a atenção dele e ele não anotava porque
eles só olhava pra si e ela ia de um
lado e um de luto o seguia
chamava atenção de todas as maneiras e
não alcançará o sucesso e ela começou a
definhar foi definhando definir ano até
que o seu corpo desapareceu restando
apenas uma voz que reproduzia o som de
outras vozes já é hora já é hora de nós
fazermos o protagonismo na nossa
comunicação é hora de nós mostrarmos a
nossa força é hora de nós conhecermos a
nossa história é hora de nós
trabalharmos a nossa voz
nós trabalhamos o nosso corpo o convite
que eu faço pra vocês é que nós não
sejamos o ego e sim
sejamos uma voz muito obrigado
[Aplausos]